[Music]
is
[Music]
is
oh
oh yeah
i'm sorry
to the
are you awesome
here
[Music]
because
um all right
[Music]
uh
okay
that's not my fault
test one two three four you don't hear
me here
all right
okay
[Music]
oh
two minute warning on the press briefing
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
is
hello
foreign
ah
hi everyone
well we have another very special guest
today
uh today we are joined by the secretary
of veterans affairs my former boss
dennis mcdonough who is working
tirelessly to build and restore
trust in the va as you all know uh
secretary mcdonough served as white
house chief of staff in the obama
biden administration for four years he
also served in several roles on the
national security council
including as principal deputy national
security adviser
throughout his service at the white
house secretary mcdonough helped lead
the obama biden administration's work
on behalf of military families and
veterans
he has a busy schedule as all of our
cabinet members do but he has kindly
agreed to also take a couple of
questions
after he speaks and i will as always be
the bad cop
uh jen thanks uh so much it's a it's a
total joy to be
uh working with you as it always is and
good afternoon to everybody here it's
nice to see
some old uh friendly faces uh
i wanna obviously thank jen for inviting
me uh today
uh to speak about the importance of the
american rescue plan
particularly as it relates to
its support to the va
to provide quality care to our veterans
especially during a very challenging
pandemic
like other hard-working americans
veterans have been severely impacted by
the coronavirus pandemic
countless veterans have lost jobs closed
businesses
homeschooled their own children and
faced uncertain prospects while our
nation grappled with the pandemic
and like the rest of the country many
veterans were directly affected by the
deadly virus
with more than 230 000 veterans in our
care infected
by it and sadly 10
605 dying from the disease
at the va we've risen to the challenge
of combating this deadly pandemic our
integrated health care system the
largest in the nation
has been running non-stop since the
start of the pandemic to provide much
needed care to infected veterans
and vaccines to those most at risk to
date
more than 1.4 million veterans have been
vaccinated
with uh more than half of them
uh having gotten both vaccines
and we're making sure that equity is at
the forefront
of where and how we distribute vaccines
at the same time we continue to deliver
routine care while mitigating the spread
of infection
va is leading the country and
standardizing the use of telehealth
for routine doctor visits we're
partnering with community
and service organizations so that vets
do not forego
checkups because of broadband
limitations last year
for example in march va averaged
approximately 2500 telehealth visits a
day
last month february we averaged nearly
45
000 such visits a day
as you can see this is a major increase
and we need the funding in the erp
to sustain this up tempo for our
veterans
so we can continue to push through the
pandemic
lastly before getting into a little bit
more detail on
the health situation the veterans
benefits administration
continues to help veterans cope with
economic impact of the pandemic
from helping veterans avoid eviction and
foreclosure to making sure that
veterans can continue to rely on their
gi bill
to pay for tuition we make sure that va
can continue to
adapt to these challenging times and the
president's american rescue plan
will do just that it will provide 17
billion in additional funding to va
to include at least 13.5 billion to
improve our ability
to provide medical service to veterans
affected by coven
272 million to cut through the backlog
of disability claims
and help us manage the compensation
exams
that have worse access to which have
worsened as a result of the pandemic
and 386 million dollars to develop a
rapid retraining program for veterans
unemployed as a result of the pandemic
now let me just give you one other uh
figure for you to consider
since the on uh start of the pandemic 19
million
appointments have been changed cancelled
or deferred as a result of the pandemic
19 million what we believe is obviously
we've been able to cut
to compensate for those through the
telehealth platforms
but not for all of them and as a result
of deferred care
which we're actually seeing across the
health care system not just
in va we're going to see increased cost
and the arp is critical to our ability
to make sure that we can keep up with
those demands of the increased cost so
our department remains fully committed
obviously to fulfilling the sacred
obligation that president
biden has made clear we have to those
who serve in uniform
the rescue plan helps us deliver on that
promise
especially in this unanticipated and
significant time
of crisis we urge the senate to pass the
much needed plan as soon as possible
and i thank you again jen for the
opportunity to be here with you
all right go ahead jeff secretary
can you explain how veterans should go
about
looking as to where to sign up for
vaccinations should they be going to the
va or should they be going to their
states and localities
it's certainly been one of the trickiest
parts of the vaccination process
to figure out information on that yeah
so i want to
i want to start by uh telling i think
what is a very positive story
um oftentimes you don't uh at least
we've not in the past been
focused on good news stories about our
scheduling process our scheduling
process is actually working pretty well
and what so the first answer jeff is
those
veterans in our care currently in the 75
and older and 65 and older
who are our particular focus at the
moment
should be hearing from our schedulers
and our schedulers are in contact with
them
and if you just take an example of the
va here
in dc they're moving through something
on someday something like 80 veterans
vaccinated in an hour now that's
obviously
because of the vaccinate tours it's
because of the pharmacists it's because
of the nurses
but it's also because of the schedulers
and they're doing an amazing bit of work
so the first thing is they should be
hearing from our schedulers
the second thing is we have a bunch of
information on our website at va.gov
including how to get access to
opportunities and then we're working
also with
vso partners and directly with veterans
through even my office whom we're
hearing from to make sure that they have
the most recent information
are there examples of frustrations
absolutely but we're staying
obviously on top of this jeff trying to
be as transparent as possible
and in the first instance reaching
veterans directly
uh to schedule them is there are there
examples of overlap too where
veterans are maybe going to the va but
also hearing from their local
or going to their state or local
facilities as well
definitely um and many of our veterans
are are
obviously this is the beauty of the
integrated system
which is we provide care across the
range of services
and so we're many of our you know the
six the over six million vets
who are with us rely on us for care
across the board uh are very
sophisticated consumers of
uh care but then we have up to nine
million who are enrolled
in the va system and they have choices
and we're seeing them make choices
um but again we are trying to be as
affirmative
and on the front foot as we can be so
that we're providing that kind of
information
i'm getting at i'm sorry to ask one more
is
isn't there some inefficiency there that
would be a problem like if
veterans just knew we can get our shots
from the va
that will clear space at these other
facilities for other people and it would
ideally give them priority
at the va yeah and and um
i i guess my my answer isn't that
there's not overlap
and that there's not competition there
obviously is but
i think what we are seeing jeff is that
we are very efficiently moving
veterans who qualify through the system
and we're hearing very positive feedback
on that there there
inevitably is going to be some overlap
and that's what we're trying to get
ahead of
with forward contacting and also
providing information as clearly as we
can about dates and times
for vaccinations how those clinics are
going to function but also not
have it just be a jump ball actually
have it be scheduled so we can get uh
efficiently get vets through the system
thank you thank you mr secretary can you
talk about what the biggest challenges
are
in getting as many veterans vaccinated
as possible
and secondly it's a part of that
hesitancy at all because i know
pentagon officials have said about a
third of troops
um have not opted to get the vaccine
yeah what are the challenges and does
that include hesitancy
well the biggest challenge is supply and
that's why we really need the american
rescue plan you've heard the president
say this you've heard jeff zion say this
you've heard uh jen say this um we have
more demand right now than there is
supply
and that's notwithstanding the fact that
uh the
covet coordinator the president have
really ins
uh really cranked up supply week on week
including with this uh these uh several
innovative
actions even over the last several days
uh with johnson and johnson and
enhancing the
manufacturing capacity so the big
challenge for us is supply
from what i hear from our docs is from
the moment we get it
our allotments are in arms within two to
three days
okay so uh i think that's a pretty
remarkable throughput
now on hesitancy you know
our lead doc on this testified last week
to congress that
in fact we're surprised that his
hesitancy is less than we feared
now that doesn't mean that we're not
going to confront it but right now
uh we're seeing uh significant demand
uh that demand outstripping supply and
that demand
consistent across categories in fact our
performance among
black vets latino vets and white vets
is pretty consistent if not
outperforming in black and latino
that's uh white vets uptake nevertheless
this is going to be a problem going
forward so we're working very closely
with our vsos
very closely with congress and then very
closely to tell the story of the
more than 1.4 million vets who have
gotten
vaccinated to date we've we're talking
about
what that experience has been um which
is
overwhelmingly positive but we need the
funding from arp
to get this done follow on the supply is
there a set amount that you're getting
every week from the administration and
have you asked
jeff science to increase that we there
is a process well-established process in
it
that's run through the interagency so we
get our allotment uh every week out of
that process
we then uh channel it out to what we
call our visions which are our regional
uh setups across the country based on
their population of the target
populations
so we have a very straightforward
transparent process by which we get our
allotment
and dish it out now i think the question
over time is
uh we're trying to demonstrate at va
that we're very efficient at moving it
through
in the hopes that as there's extra that
it comes our way
so for example about three weeks ago
there's 200 000 doses
that was additive to our allotment and
we as with everything else we're getting
we move that quickly through the system
into vets arms
uh on a very clear efficient uh process
on another topic uh as the the capital's
on alert today i want to ask you about
the veterans who played a role
in the january 6th attack we've seen
30-plus veterans be arrested for
participating
we see these militia groups that are
actively trying to recruit
veterans what if anything can the va do
are you considering doing
to try and combat some of this yeah so i
also
just to fill out the story i also saw
veterans on that day
including members of congress who were
veterans doing remarkable things
including members of the
dcpd and the capital pd veterans doing
remarkable things
and so i think it's a full picture there
that underscores that
basically veterans continue to play a
critical role
uh in the country even after
they uh retire from active duty and
we're very proud of that
as to the questions you raise uh we'll
we'll take a look at that we don't have
anything specific to announce now
but again i want to make sure that we
have a full picture of
things like remarkable members in the
house
mr gallego is one who comes to mind um
you know senator cotton in the senate
these people taking
concrete action and supported democracy
on the ground that day
they're vets too phil
thank you mr secretary two of you don't
mind the first one who related
um you talked about missed appointments
and kind of the
what covent has taken away when it comes
to suicide
uh what is the va doing right now
tangibly to reach out to veterans
proactively not just messaging campaigns
though i know those are important
but to proactively reach out to veterans
to ensure that needs in that
general area are being met yeah it's a
major it's a major priority for
obvious reasons and it's heartbreaking
every uh
any individual suicide is absolutely
heartbreaking
and we're very focused on reducing these
the most important uh set of lessons i
think we have to draw from is
the availability of telehealth platform
demand
for mental health services is up i think
that's a good sign
because it speaks to the fact that
stigma is being reduced
however there's still too much um
and that is part of
uh that's the first half of the answer
to your question which is we're not just
passive waiting for vets to come to us
we're also then working with our
providers
and with local communities to ensure
that
we have a good sense of at-risk vets and
that we're establishing contact
and ways to be in contact with them
affirmatively lastly congress has given
us additional
authorities on this and we're going to
use them the hannan act was just enacted
in fact i was just speaking with
senator bozeman from arkansas about this
earlier this week he and senator tester
spent a lot of time on this question
giving us new authority to make grants
in local communities
using local providers who know their
communities best
to ensure that we're providing
assistance to those vets
at risk vets and making sure that we're
doing things like reducing the stigma
so uh that's what we're that's what
we're uh doing phil
just real quick from a policy question i
know this came up during your
confirmation hearing but do you have a
plan right now to either reverse or
significantly revise the
community access standards through the
va mission act i don't have a specific
plan on that i'm
very an active discussion with people
like senator moran center tester senator
sanders
about what we're seeing we're also
beginning to get data
about last fiscal year what happened in
the community
um this is the data we're getting now is
pre
covid so basically first quarter and a
half of
fy20 um and what we're seeing there is a
pretty significant uptake in the
community and so we gotta
a be a good partner with that ensure
that we're paying those bills on time to
local providers
we're keeping vibrant networks so our
people have places
uh that they can find care but we also
have to be
really careful that we're also
maintaining investment in the integrated
system of the va itself
we have to recapitalize that make sure
that these institutions many of them
over 50 years old are brought up to
speed the arp will be important to that
too
things like new hvac new air control
systems
zero uh pressure rooms so we're not
moving that virus
through the hospital those are all
things that are gonna be
enabled by the aarp and that's why we
really need the senate to get this done
all right let's do the last question
then we'll have to have them come back
go ahead thank you mr secretary at the
top of your remarks you mentioned the
importance of keeping veterans in their
homes
the moratorium on forbearance and
foreclosures of course was extended
through june do you think it should be
extended further well we'll take a look
at that and we're taking a look at a lot
of those
uh those things in incidentally and
importantly
uh in the arp is additional funding for
homelessness
programming uh we know that this
continues to
uh to um bedevil us
uh as a country it's an outrage any
night that any vet
is homeless where you know over the last
10 years down 50 percent on those
numbers
but they're creeping back up as a result
of the pandemic and 50
while progress is nowhere near where we
need to be
so we need that funding in the erp thank
you so much secretary
thank you to come back yeah thank you
very much it's great to see everybody
thank you all right a couple of other
things at the top
uh as you all saw many of you reported
on this morning uh the numbers from the
labor department out show the 50th week
in a row
with new unemployment claims exceed
where new unemployment
claims exceeded their pre-pandemic high
hundreds of thousands of americans are
continuing to struggle in this economy
we can't get numb to what this
represents these are moms and dads
friends and neighbors who will now have
to worry about how they'll support
families
put food on the table and make ends meet
in the midst of a pandemic
this also underscores the need for
congress to move quickly to pass the
american rescue plan
to get 1400 checks to the american
people you may have also seen today if
you're covering economic issues i should
say
that the treasury department announced a
new program called emergency capital
investment program called the emergency
capital investment program
through this program treasury will make
a nine billion dollar investment
in community financial institutions that
have a track record
in investing in financially underserved
communities
which have been particularly hurt by the
pandemic this support will bolster these
institutions so they can continue to
play
important roles in fostering financial
inclusion for communities that have been
shut out
for far too long this component this
program is one component of treasury's
efforts to combat economic inequality
this one announced today is one of three
treasury programs totaling about 12
billion dollars
as you also know in an hour or so the
president the vice president the
secretary of transportation
will meet with bipartisan members of the
house transportation and infrastructure
committee
this meeting is meant to build on the
conversation the president had with a
bipartisan group
of senators on february 11th investing
in our nation's infrastructure is a top
priority for the president something
he's talked about
as a part of his build back better
agenda also back to when he was vice
president
uh serving and the last or the last
democratic administration
he believes we have to rebuild our
crumbling roads and bridges improve our
communities
and create good union jobs for americans
chris also tells me he'll get
secretaries buddha judge here to talk to
all of you so
we're relying on him for that um one
last piece
i can't remember who was but somebody in
here asked about mississippi
and the water situation on the ground in
mississippi so as i mentioned i would we
followed up with our fema team
we're of course continuing to closely
monitor the situation in jackson
mississippi
we're not currently tracking any
requests for federal assistance through
fema from the governor which is how of
course
that process works as it relates to
jackson
the mississippi state national guard has
numerous water distribution sites in
place
and the federal government including the
epa remains in close touch with the
governor and mayor to offer support alex
why don't you kick us off sure thanks
jen
um good question let's start with
international what is the us doing
to help free ap journalist teams in and
other journalists detained in myanmar
including the ongoing crackdown against
protesters there has there been
any outreach to authorities there and
what's been the response
uh well i will say first that the
detainment of journalists uh
the the targeting of journalists and
dissidents is certainly something that
is of great concern to the president to
the secretary of state and to
every member of our administration and
certainly this issue has been raised
with
the issue broadly is raised in virtually
every diplomatic conversation
uh that uh members of our team have uh
as you're very
uh familiar with the situation on the
ground uh in burma
is uh troubling uh we've obviously been
working closely with our partners in the
region
we've taken sanctioned steps as you know
to
make it send a clear message that it's
unacceptable i don't have any diplomatic
conversations to update you on this
would likely happen through the state
department so i would
certainly suggest you um reach out to
them directly
domestically we've seen a couple of
high-profile id reports out this week
about former trump officials
does the president believe that
inspector general should continue to
investigate and potentially pursue
punitive measures against
these trump officials that are no longer
in office or does he think it's time to
turn the page well as you know the
department of transportation officer of
inspector general initiated the
investigation
into the former secretary during the
trump administration
and completed the investigation under
the leadership of a trump appointed
inspector general
the inspector generals across agencies
are independent for a reason
and we certainly respect their role in
moving forward or seeing those
investigations through as they see fit
uh go ahead uh the governor of
mississippi has responded to the
president's comments yesterday and he
seems to have taken offense at some of
the president's language uh
he says mississippians don't need
handlers i just think we should trust
americans
and not insult them he's making argument
that this is really about personal
liberty here
does the president have any second
thoughts about the language that he used
yesterday and
how does comparing someone to a
neanderthal help convince them to change
course and get on board with your public
health message the behavior of a
neanderthal just to be very clear
um the behavior of look i think the
president uh what we what everybody saw
yesterday was a reflection of
his frustration and exasperation which i
think many
american people have that for almost a
year now
uh people across the country have
sacrificed uh and many times they
haven't had information they need from
the federal government they haven't had
access to a greater understanding of
what the public health guidelines should
look like
and those include many many people in
mississippi and texas
in ohio florida in every state across
the country
and you know he believes that with more
than half a million americans lives lost
with families that continue to suffer
that it's imperative
that people listen across the country
whether they live in a red state or blue
state
to the guidance of public health experts
at the same time
you've watched the president closely for
some time mary as you all have
he's going to engage with and talk with
people who disagree with him on a range
of issues including this one
but he believes that if we're going to
get this pandemic under control we need
to follow public health guidelines
he simply has was asked asked the
american people to abide by wearing
masks for 100 days right about day 40
are we at day 40 around there
60 more days uh that's what he's asking
he's certainly hopeful that
businesses and people across the country
will continue to do that have you
reached out to governors
to convince them to try and change
course here
i don't think uh his view on mask
wearing is a secret they're certainly
familiar with it he's talked about it
many many times and i'm certain when he
speaks with them next
uh he will convey that directly the
president has said that he hopes
you know he's hopeful that by this time
next year we may be getting
some semblance of normalcy again is
there a concern
that as we see states like mississippi
and texas take these actions if others
follow suit
that that could shift the timeline that
a few states could
set back the timeline here well well
what the president has said publicly and
certainly conveyed to all of us
is he can't do this alone the federal
government cannot do this alone
this is going to require additional
sacrifice
from the american people he doesn't
think that's easy none of us think
that's easy
but he has ordered enough vaccines to
ensure everybody in the country
is vaccinated and he will we will have
those vaccines by the end of may
but it will require ongoing social
distancing ongoing mass squaring as
we've been talking about
and it will also require the american
people getting the vaccine
he can't force individuals to do that so
he can just project
the recommendations of public health
officials
he can take steps as he has over the
last couple of days to ensure
that communities are prioritized who are
playing
key roles in society but he can't do it
on behalf
of the public and it is going to require
the public to play an important and
vital role here too
the president has been pretty critical
of the prior administration's handling
of this pandemic saying you inherited
a mess here but when it comes to
vaccinations you are following some of
the same playbook here so does the prior
administration
deserve some credit for laying the
groundwork which ones are we following
well for instance uh former trump hhs
assistant secretary
admiral brett gerard has said that
you're following 99 of the playbook they
created on vaccines
uh he has said that the prior
administration deserves more credit here
for at least getting the ball rolling on
some of these
i don't think anyone deserves credit
when half a million people in the
country have died of this pandemic
so what our focus is on and when the
president's focus is on when he came
into office just over a month ago
was ensuring that we had enough vaccines
we have that we are going to have them
now
we had enough vaccinators and we had
enough vaccine locations
to get this pandemic under control
there's no question and all data points
to the fact that there were not enough
of
any of those things when he took office
we are open-eyed about the challenge we
continue to
live under and that's why he has been
focused every single day and doing
everything possible to get the pandemic
on control
uh but those were there were shortages
in all those areas uh which were
preventing us from moving forward on
getting the pandemic under control go
ahead um
the previous administration put it into
regular reporting of specific troop
levels in afghanistan iraq
and syria i understand this is the
pentagon's failure but will the
president commit
to once again reporting specific troop
levels in those three countries under
his administration
well um certainly uh we of course would
work with the pentagon and our national
security team
to ensure that transparency uh remains
uh
a priority or is re-prioritized i should
say under this invest
under this administration i mean i'd
have to talk to our national security
team and our
uh team at the pentagon about um any
restrictions they have but that remains
a
a vital priority for this president and
something i know he's projecting to his
entire team
last night when the president was
speaking to house democrats he said i
know we're all making small compromises
as he tried to work everybody
to support the bill or thank them for
supporting their version of the bill
what exactly has the president asked
moderates to compromise on
in this process up to this point you'd
have to ask them
that question uh you know the president
has been clear that he is unmovable
on the sides of the package 1.9 trillion
dollars
and as you know from covering the hill
uh that is not that was a size that some
expressed concern about he has been
unmovable about his view that
americans who need help the most should
get 1400 checks
there were some who spoke openly about
their concern about that
and he has been very clear that state
and local governments
need assistance now to keep cops on the
beat to keep teachers
uh you know to keep firefighters
employed and to keep state and local
governments functioning
i'm sure there may be other issues that
they have concerns about i'll let them
speak to that but
he has been uh insistent that uh the
scope of the challenge requires this
size of a package
and in order to adjust stress these twin
trace crises that we're facing
and needs to have these key components
included and then last one
again from the president last night the
house democrats um he made the point
that this will make everything more
possible to get done
get done i think i'm quoting properly um
passing this now
is that the kind of theory of the case
here you get this done
at this scam and all of a sudden some of
the difficulties you may have in the u.s
senate
um become less so because people see
uh that you were able to produce i just
want to make sure that i understand kind
of his thought process
i'm not sure what the context of that
comment was can you tell me more of the
context of it i don't have a full
thinking for me sorry about that let me
just start because he said uh
you know paraphrase promise of being
accurate when i paraphrase this
um that the idea being that if they get
this done there will be more trust in
government if there's more trust in
government therefore
people will be willing to get behind
maybe the priorities that house
democrats have
going forward whether that's on
infrastructure whether it's on climate
any of those things he didn't list those
off
and so i guess that's my question is
does the administration look at
the american rescue plan and say this is
our springboard
to doing even more
broad-based more bold in the words of
the administration
legislative proposals in the future we
don't look at it through a
as political legislative as a of a lens
as you just outlined but i will say that
uh the president came into office
knowing that getting the pandemic under
control
uh helping address and put people back
to work the millions and millions
of americans who are struggling to make
ends meet the one in seven
american families that can't put food on
the table that he knew
that those would be his top two
priorities his top one two three four
pandemic economic recovery pandemic
economic recovery
and that is what this package is meant
to help address
and what i've heard him say and this
sounds consistent with that
well i don't know the full context of
this is that of course he wants to
uh build on he builds his agenda
beyond um built his agenda beyond
getting the pandemic under control
beyond addressing and stemming the tide
of a finding of an economic crisis
because he believes that investing in
infrastructure uh is imperative and long
overdue
he believes that modernizing our
immigration system
is uh long overdue and is good for the
american people good for our economy
he believes there needs to be more done
for caregiving he believes we need to do
more to protect our health
to ensure uh people more people have
access to health care so
there's no question that he he views uh
his
the early stage early uh part of his
presidency as focused on these twin
crises
but he is hardly going to be done with
his agenda and work
once we have this package signed into
law uh go ahead
thanks jen does the president believe
that the house ways and means committee
should have be able to obtain donald
trump's tax returns
would we certainly leave that up to them
the president spoke about this on the
campaign trail but his
focus at this point is not looking
backward at the former guy as he has
called him in the past
but yesterday the treasury and
administration at large
uh asked for more time on how to respond
to the subpoena he won't
weigh in on that president we'll leave
it to the treasury department
department of justice and our focus is
on getting relief to the american people
uh on getting the pandemic under control
that's keeping us pretty busy so we'll
leave that work to
others in the federal government and in
congress go ahead more if i can
economic base sure um gasoline prices
are approaching three dollars per gallon
for the first time since 2014.
uh americans as you well know are cash
trapped
is the president planning to to
intervene somehow opec plus came up this
morning
and said they were going to limit supply
does the president plan to intervene
somehow maybe call
the saudi government russia anything in
the toolbox to rein in the gas prices
i don't have anything on that to preview
for you um i will say since you've given
me
uh sort of an opportunity and opening
here is that there's been a lot of
reporting on
um kind of what kind of relief would
come out of the american rescue plan
something that can help address a range
of issues the american people are having
whether it's
the cost of gas or it's the uh inability
or concern about getting food on the
table so let me just take this
opportunity to lay out some of the
specific
numbers our nec team i love number
crunchers crunched
for all of you so under the senate
version of the bill
158.5 million households are going to
receive direct payments
that's 98 of the households who receive
them
in december and in the previous round of
relief that two percent sliver
all received checks smaller than six
hundred dollars in some cases as small
as a hundred dollars because as you all
know is scaled down after a certain
income rate
under the rescue plan almost all of
these 180
158.5 million households are going to
receive checks that are more than twice
the size of the previous round
not to mention the 66 million kids who
will benefit from the expanded child tax
credit
and 17 million adults who will then have
been who will benefit from the expanded
earned income
tax credit because of course there are
many tax components as you all know
in addition to the direct checks that
are included in this package
so just wanted to give a little number
crunching lay down go ahead jeff
uh jen going back to texas and
mississippi
is the white house concerned and the
cova team concerned
that the loosening or lifting of
restrictions in those states
will lead to these cova variants to
spread
more well one of the reasons that
our health and medical experts have
continued to call for the american
people to wear a mass
to social distance to get whatever
vaccine they have access to
is because many of them have of these
vaccines have shown to be effective
in addressing the variance and because
we've seen a spread of variance
reportedly in some of these states so i
would say jeff that you know
our concern here is on the health
welfare well-being
and survival frankly of people across
the country
and in states where the guidelines are
not or where the recommendations
from leadership is not following health
and medical guidelines we have concerns
about the impact on the population
you know in europe there are there are
travel restrictions between european
states the united states is large and
there's 50 states
is there any discussion of of
restrictions for traveling between
states
when different states have such
different ideas about how to fight covid
and would you encourage or discourage
other americans from traveling to texas
or mississippi right now
i'm not aware of any discussions and i
certainly wouldn't do that from here
but i would just say jeff that um
you know we are um we are going to
continue to use uh
every bully pull every method of the
bully pulpit at our disposal to convey
directly
uh to people living across the country
including in many of these states that
mask wearing social distancing getting
access to the vaccine
is the path to go back to normal um and
that is how we are going to get it done
and how the american people can return
to
believe me i'd love to take my kids to
birthday parties and to parks and to go
to a restaurant i've
been to one in a year uh you know we all
want that this is the pathway to do that
and that's what we'll continue to convey
go ahead more quickly on another topic
i'm sorry
but yeah the capital was on uh high
alert today because of the
potential of an attack related to
conspiracy theory about
this date is the white house taking any
additional security measures
and can you share any uh intel
or readout about what you know about the
threat
uh well let me first say jeff that um on
the specifics of today's threats um
the fbi and dhs have warned that the
threat from domestic violence extremism
particularly racially motivated
and anti-government extremists did not
begin or end on january 6th
and we have been vigilant day in and day
out
our our national security and homeland
security team has been
since then uh in part because we are
witnessing a years-long trend of false
narratives fueling violence
and the current heightened security
environment in the national capital
region writ large
uh is an illustration of that uh i i'm
not going to
um to outline any security uh security
steps from here at any point in time
but i can say that uh our team is of
course uh
remain the our team the president uh
personally remains deeply engaged in
uh in uh tracking these threats uh and
receiving regular updates as he does
from his team about
threats of course but about incidents
happening across the country it's
something he has
uh personally engaged in uh it's
reflected in the comprehensive review he
ordered in his first week of the job
he's also a diligent and con an eager
consumer of intelligence uh
and as you'd expect appropriate elements
of the intelligent community and law
enforcement
uh are providing a steady pace of
information and analysis
on a regular basis on domestic violent
extremism in the country
go ahead thank you jen um as more people
are getting vaccinated every day there's
still a lack of clarity about what they
should and shouldn't do and we've
reported that the cdc guidance for them
was supposed to be
released today but that's no do you have
any guidance about why not
and when americans should expect to see
recommendations
uh i would certainly point you to the
cdc i believe
they said in your story or maybe another
story perhaps that
the cdc's guidance will not be posted
tomorrow this is a quote from them
because we have not finalized it here at
cdc once it is final we will publish and
disseminate it
uh and certainly we know people are
eager to hear more details about
steps they can take once they're
vaccinated and we certainly
think that once people have a sense of
that hopefully and
we'll see it when we see it um it will
uh hopefully encourage people to get
vaccinated
as well but uh they're on their own
timeline and we'll wait to see when
they're ready to put out that guidelines
so the white house
has not seen them yet i'm not aware of
the white house reviewing
the guidelines now on texas
governor abbott said that the biden
administration
must stop importing povid into the
country
um because he claims that coveted
positive migrants
are being bussed into texas and then
sent to other places
in the country did you ever respond to
that and can you
elaborate on what the government is
doing to test
migrants with anything sure well we're
around fact we're about facts around
here that is not factual
um so let me give you an overview of
what happens
when migrants are placed in alternatives
to detention
uh their covid19 testing our policy
is for covid19 testing to be done at the
state and local level and with the help
of ngos and local
governments and that certainly is
something that our policy is is for
to have that be done uh concluded
before they are even moved to go stay
with family members or
others they may know while their cases
are being adjudicated
um and of course our guidance to anyone
uh regardless of status as testing
positive for cova 19 or experiencing
covet like symptoms is uh you know to
social distance to wear a mask and seek
medical attention
as needed but uh you know in general uh
our approach and our policy
is to uh work with local governments
work with ngos to
ensure to have testing to ensure these
migrants are tested
uh and that can take place and that
steps for isolation quarantining and
medical
care can be taken should that be needed
is there a reason why the burden is on
state and local jurisdictions to do the
testing and not the federal government
well many of these ngos are have stepped
in to help
ensure that these steps can be taken
many of these ngos have also
if quarantining or issue or isolation is
needed have even reserved hotel blocks
in some cases and you certainly have to
talk to some of them about the steps
they take
but obviously their assistance is it
allows uh allows the federal government
to uh you know work with
local communities to get this done thank
you
just one more question on migrants
specifically unaccompanied
minors who continue to come to the
border every day
we've reported that 96 of the hhs beds
are already accounted for is the
administration planning to open
new influx facilities specifically for
these children um
and maybe at military bases or
installations like we've seen in the
past
uh well i'm not in a position to confirm
the specific
numbers i can say that we are there are
of course a large number of
unaccompanied minors who are coming
across the border and as you know
because we've talked about it in here we
believe that the humane approach
is to treat these kids with humanity and
and ensure that they have a safe place
to be
uh well i don't have anything to preview
for you in terms of considerations
underway at this point in time
but obviously we recognize that with the
number that are coming in
and the limited facilities we have and
the
uh our desire to abide by coveted
protocols um
that uh you know it's a policy process
that is uh imperative and
a priority for the this administration
good uh senate republicans have made
pretty clear that they intend to block
uh major democratic legislation given
what the president has said about that
uh is he giving more thought to the
filibuster in making changes to that is
he having discussions on that front
which piece of legislation are they
intending to block hr1
policing reform uh there's some
union-related
legislation that the house is looking at
next week well our view is that voting
rights
um that uh you know addressing
needed reforms of unions that moving
forward on
a number of long overdue uh policy uh
efforts by congress is
is too important uh to prejudge what the
outcome will be and we've certainly seen
the
threats by uh some in congress but we're
going to continue to
work to see if there's a bipartisan path
forward so he is not considering
looking at the filibuster pressing his
senate his policy has not changed his
his
on that issue uh he believes that uh
there is a path forward uh to work with
democrats and republicans to get
business done for the american people
and he'll continue to make that case
and secondly why hasn't the president
signed the paperwork to lift the
the raise the refugee cap the state
department has been booking flights but
has since canceled those
well i would refer you to the state
department i know that they have to have
uh systems in place in order to
implement policies like that but i they
have we'll have more details on where
things stand
and just lastly on on hr one it includes
some restrictions on
uh so-called dark money secret money uh
the president uh
his allies have just formed an outside
group will he
will he uh instruct them to make those
donors to that group
public as rather than keeping them
secret well i'm not sure he's in the
position to instruct
them that's not the relationship we have
but he certainly can
i would refer you to them on what their
policy is going to be for making donors
public
position right and he's spoken to this
issue in the past but
i don't have anything to i would point
you to the outside group to for any
further comment on that
go ahead ashley thanks jen a few
questions there were a few late changes
in the covid relief bill that could help
several states including
alaska by increasing funding for lower
population states
as well as adding money for tourism and
seafood processors
did president biden sign off on these
changes personally and was this aimed at
all
i would say the majority of negotiations
at this point are between
senators themselves in congress uh and
uh those are where that's where the
discussions are of course the president
is engaged with members as you know who
are here sometimes in the oval office
who he talks to on the phone but
i'm not going to outline uh any more
particulars for you other than
the majority of negotiation is between
senators in congress
schools we knew the administration's
goal for the first 100 days
can you talk a little bit about what the
public should expect for the fall when
the new school year will start what the
goal is and what the reasonable
expectation should be
we don't have new goals to outline but i
would tell you that now that we have a
secretary of education in place
his number one priority is ensuring
schools are open that they're open five
days a week
uh that schools have the information
they need to put in place the mitigation
steps
obviously we need the money from the
american rescue plan to get that done
in certain communities uh but our
objective is for schools to certainly be
open
fair is it a reasonable expectation for
parents and families to expect that kids
will be
back in a what we think it was a more
traditional classroom setting five days
a week
for the next grade in the fall well that
certainly is our hope and our objective
but the secretary of education is going
to be leading this effort he's going to
have a summit he's announced
he's going to be working closely to help
school districts implement work with
them to implement
uh these guidelines that have been put
out by the cdc and so
i expect he'll have more to say on it
lastly how quickly does president biden
plan to move
to name a replacement for near camden i
don't expect to have an announcement
this week
uh beyond that i don't have anything to
preview for you i would say our focus
right now is on getting the
nearly half a dozen cabinet nominees
including our nominee to be the attorney
general of the united states
uh through congress because those are
essential roles we need to have in place
leading this department
as you know he's nominated an incredibly
qualified and well-respected
uh woman shalonda young to be the deputy
at omb
and we're certainly hopeful congress
will move forward on that and then she
would be in a place to be the acting
head in the while we go through the
process of nominating a replacement for
near
good um on the border is the white house
or the administration planning to ask
fema to assist with the influx of
children coming across the border and if
so
does that mean that you consider it an
actual genuine emergency
well i would say that that's probably a
question for the department of homeland
security uh who obviously
oversees that and the department of home
health and human services who oversees
the facilities and the shelters where
uh these kids are um certainly one of
our concerns is that
um there are there is a you know as we
were talking about earlier
an influx of kids at a rate and a pace
um that uh is going to require us to
uh you know make considerations about
where we're going to safely
house them um and that is something that
is under discussion in the
administration uh but
i don't have any i would just send you
to them who oversee the department of
homeland security oversees the process
um in the current stimulus proposal the
um child tax credit is expanded
temporarily from two thousand to three
thousand dollars
did the president support making that
expansion permanent or any of the other
temporary expansions in the bill
permanent
well he's the president is interested in
exploring options for making the child
tax credit permanent
uh as part of the build back better
agenda he's been heartened to see
bipartisan support for ideas like this
including from
republicans like senator romney but uh
we'll have more to say about all of that
once we get the rescue plan passed
just one more um the president has
traveled back to wilmington a couple of
times since taking office
the cdc does still urge people not to
travel for personal reasons
obviously presidential travel is very
different than commercial travel but
should the president be doing more to
set an example about personal travel
during the pandemic well the president
lives in wilmington
um it's his home that's where he's lived
for many many years
and as you know as any president of the
united states does he takes a private
airplane called air force one to travel
there that is of course a unique
uh unique from most americans but i
think most americans would also see that
as a unique circumstance
um go ahead thank you jen um so a group
of 9 11 families did a letter of to
president
biden this week and they're asking that
the fbi that he declassified fbi
documents
that talk about this value link to the
september 11th terror attacks
would this be something that president
biden would consider i would send you
the department of justice
another question four years ago this
week president trump uh announced that
he was going to donate the first quarter
of his salary
uh basically back to the government
wondering obviously realizing very
different financial circumstances
but we don't know we haven't seen his
tax returns that's true i'm not sure but
will the president
consider donating a portion of his
salary either back to the government
or to a charity of his choice i'm happy
to talk to him about that and get back
to you directly
or others who are interested go ahead in
the back hi um
sit down into the irish times just sort
of changes
even we're in march fewer than less than
two weeks away from saint patrick's day
uh i was wondering what are the white
house plans to mark st patrick's day we
do know that the president president
biden
is very proud of its irish heritage and
just wanted to know do you have any
update on the plans for that
uh i don't have an update on specific
plans but uh the president uh
has a special place in his heart for uh
the irish as do i
um and i expect certainly we'll have
more details to share
um in the coming uh soon given news who
said it's two weeks away
of course uh any uh any uh recognition
of saint patrick's day would look
different but from past years but we
will certainly mark
the day and we'll have more to say on it
as we get closer and there's a second
question
on trade this morning the biden
administration
uh suspended tariffs on uk exports as
part of the the boeing airbus ongoing
refused
um but also on the trade on on this area
today and their continuing tensions
around brexit in northern ireland and
the uk has been accused of
reneging on international law for the
second time over
um a delay in imposing checks between
northern ireland
and great britain just those two aspects
in terms of a uk us trade deal
where did two things stand now in the
administration
is a uk us deal trade deal a priority
for this administration
or are they concerned president biden
said before that and i quote any
trade deal between the us and uk must be
contingent upon respect for the good
friday agreement in order
uh so that remains certainly remains the
case
um i will say since you brought up and
everybody may not be following
the suspension of tariffs news this
morning
in a joint statement the united states
united kingdom announced a four-month
suspension of terrorists related to the
ongoing large
civilian aircraft dispute and the
four-month tariff suspension was agreed
to
ease the burden on industry and take a
bold joint step towards resolving the
longest running dispute
one of the longest refunding disputes at
the world trade organization
and certainly the president's president
biden has been an unequivocal
unequivocal i should say in his support
for the good friday agreement
this agreement has been the bedrock of
peace stability and prosperity for all
the people of northern ireland we
are also welcome cooperation between our
british and irish partners on the
northern ireland irish protocol
and the recent strong statements on
these government's full commitment to
the good
friday agreement on the boeing dispute
um
the fact that the uk has moved to
suspend these tariffs on uk exports is
this a sign
that the u.s is prepared to reach some
kind of negotiation settlement with the
eu
on the tariffs on this very long-running
uh disagreement over bowling and airbus
i don't have anything to preview for you
on that um this is just of course
an announcement made this morning it was
meant to de-escalate the issue and
create space for a negotiated
settlement to the airbus and boeing
disputes but in terms of additional
steps i don't have anything to preview
for you
go ahead thank you jim now you mentioned
earlier on masks you reckon you
reference the president's
uh frustration and exasperation with
people who
were not following the science uh it
would appear
uh that notwithstanding there are still
millions of americans out there who
are not following the science certainly
in places like texas mississippi and
south carolina and other places
so i'm wondering why doesn't the
president consider
ratcheting up his rhetoric beyond
neanderthal
and personalizing his concern why
doesn't for example
why doesn't he think about saying folks
here's the deal you don't wear your mask
people are going to die because of you
that would certainly get people's
attention
well noted i will say the president has
been clear
that if people wear masks for 100 days
60 000 lives could be saved and he has
been clear he did a whole psa during the
super bowl about it about
the benefit and impact of mask wearing
uh
he also though uh does not believe that
people of any state
or any american um should be um
hurt by the guidance of their leadership
and so that's why he's spoken directly
to the american people
we all have or we all are trying to
about the impact of mask wearing of
social distancing and of taking
the vaccine uh when people can have
access to it
go ahead in the back um you were in
china
what does the president expect from the
europeans in terms of confronting
china which he calls a strategic
competitor and
how does the president see the china
investment deal which they struck
shortly before he took office well i
will say first that in the president's
engagements with
uh leaders in the european union which
were many of his first and early
uh discussions uh in gay
the relationship with china and working
together in partnership and in lockstep
was certainly central to all of those
discussions
uh and uh you know in terms of the
specific
um trade agreement or trade or
negotiations i guess i should say
that was announced shortly before he
took office i believe
we spoke to that at the time i don't
think i have anything new to preview or
convey to you at that
about that thank you oh sorry i didn't
get to one person
sorry alex go ahead go ahead i
appreciate it uh two questions first of
all
um i wanted to ask about uh something
we're hearing from
a lot of republican uh senators on some
of the nominees at epa and energy
is the idea that they oppose them not
necessarily because of the nominees
themselves
but because they believe they'll be
taking orders from white house advisers
gina mccarthy john kerry
just wondering if you could respond to
that and talk about how the white house
envisions
their role in relation to the actual
senate confirmed heads of those agencies
it really depends on the agency as
you well know some are independent some
are not independent
obviously anyone who's a nominee to lead
a cabinet agency
um that is not independent is there in
part
to deliver on the agenda and the
policies of the president of the united
states and they certainly know that when
they walk into the jobs
but he also welcomes debate and welcomes
proposals and welcomes
ideas on how to address the various
crises we're facing including
the climate crisis uh so it really
depends on who you're speaking to or
what who you're speaking about
uh you know i think the president's uh
feels confident
that his nominees across the board are
qualified they're experienced
they're prepared to do the job and he's
eager to have his team
in place and hopeful that the senate
moves forward to confirm the remainder
of his nominees
and if i i could also um any white house
reaction to
um microsoft uh and this hack
uh that they're talking about as the
president um
taking steps being kept up to date being
briefed on this
i'd have to talk to our uh cyber team
about that um and see if there have been
any updates or briefings on our end oh
go ahead ashley um
following up on shalonda young you said
that the hope is that she'll be the
acting
director she has a ton of support on
capitol hill from the cbc
from has democratic leadership uh why is
the administration
not just gone ahead and nominated her to
be the
official director well the one the
president thinks so highly of her he
nominated her to be the deputy director
of omb which is a
very senior and significant job and role
in the administration
all i was conveying is how the process
works if the debt
when the deputy is confirmed knock on
wood they will then become the acting
director hence there is a
need and an imperative to move forward
on that quickly
uh i will reserve his space for him
making his own decision about who is
going to lead
the budget department we certainly know
there's lots of support on capitol hill
and again he thinks so highly of her he
nominated her to serve in a senior role
so highly of her um i guess why is the
obvious
next step not just to appoint her to
that top position
well actually there's a range of
individuals in the country who are
qualified for the job
so uh we'll leave him the space and time
to make a decision about
who he'd like to nominate as a
replacement for nira tandon
okay last one actually i'm sorry we've
gone over now go ahead uh
jen just a quick uh follow-up did the
president directly speak to alabama
governor kay ivey who's actually said
that she's going to
extend her she did and i meant to raise
that um i'm not aware of a direct
conversation between them today
obviously the president's uh view uh
and uh his support for the mass mandate
um and encouraging people to wear masks
given the advice of his health and
medical experts is well known
it's something he's raised on calls with
governors our health and cova team is
raised on calls with governors
uh but i'm not aware of a direct call
between them today do you know if he's
talked to any other republicans who
might be flirting with this idea of
opening prematurely i don't have any
other calls to read out for you at this
point in time thanks so much everyone
you